hey guys what's up? now there's been a
lot of you that asked me hey Daniel
please give me a few tips to be more
attractive not just look attractive but
to be more attractive or just to look a
little bit better. so in this video I'm
gonna give you 23 tips to be more
attractive and if you stick until the
end I'll give you a bonus tip as well so
let's get into the video.
alright now let's be honest whether you
are single and still looking for that
special girl out there or if you already
have someone we guys we want to be more
attractive to them right? well luckily
there are always things that you can
improve on to make yourself better or
more attractive so let's start with tip
number one always dress just a little
bit better than the situation requires
don't overdress or underdress. be
self-confident, focus on your strengths
and remember you are unique. so remember
to smile relax and keep your composure
in all situations.
always use deodorant and find a very
good cologne that suits you when you
find it use it every day and pretty soon
people will identify that smell with you
if you're not sure which colognes to use
I'll add a few of my favorites in the
video description so you can check it
out. never have bad breath. there's a lot of
guys out there they floss and brush
their teeth every day which is great but
they forget about their tongue. if you
have this white kind of discolouring
on your tongue then chances are you have
bad breath. so scrape it off.
avoid
looking like you've been trying too hard
with your clothing styles. the people who
dress the best looks like they've just
happened to put these clothing styles on
and they look cool they don't look like
they've been obsessing over it. remember
it's not just what you wear it's how you
wear it.
adopt a habit of walking and sitting
with a straight back. if you strengthen
the muscles in your back it will make it
a lot easier so don't skip those back
exercises at the gym.
start to use a good face cream every day.
it will protect you against the Sun and
ultimately those wrinkles that will make
you look older than you really are.
if you don't really know which products to
use. I'll add a few of my favorites in
the video description. be more empathetic
towards others and less selfish. think
about the feelings and interests of
other people a lot more because that
will ultimately help you to communicate
with them a lot better. take good
care of your shoes. apart from making you
look better cleaning and polishing your
shoes every now and then will make the
shoes last longer and save you
money
if you wear socks make sure the socks
match the pants and please throw away
all the socks with the holes in them.
yeah you know what I'm talking about.
clean your ears. for those guys that
have those hair poking out of the ears:
yes that also means you got to trim it.
if you feel that your face is not that
attractive, like the symmetry is not all
there. what you can do is grow a cool
beard style. some men look a lot better
with a beard. it's like they've been born
to wear one
so why shave it? just trim it,
style it and maintain it.
stop wearing stuff that are meant for
specific tasks. like for example:
flip-flops they're meant for the beach
and the pool. hiking boots for hiking.
I feel like I almost don't have to say this,
but you got to start eating better. your
body will thank you for it and you will
not only look better you will feel
better as well. if you're not sure what
to eat check out my male model diet plan
after this video.
all right another tip that I almost feel
like I don't really want to mention
because it's kind of common sense but
you gotta exercise. if you hate exercise
try just two days a week for one hour. or get
a bike or start a new sport. just get
moving you will really start to have
more energy and you will also feel a lot
better.
then clothes will look a lot better
on you as well.
have at least one pair of good classic
oxford shoes. when someone else is talking
especially if it's a girl, give your full
attention. think about it, how do you feel
like if you've been talking for a while
and you just realized this person
doesn't listen to you at all and also
never interrupt someone else when they
are talking because then they will feel
disrespected.
when you go shopping, bring a brutally
honest friend that you can trust. if they
tell you hey this outfit is not looking
good, don't be angry they're just trying
to help you.
never ask a salesperson that are there
because they need to make their
Commission, rather  trust your friend.
choose the right haircut for your face
remember your face is also changing over
time go and look at some old photos and
you'll see it. this also means that the
hairstyle that used to work for you
might not work for you anymore. if you're
happy with your haircut, use the right
styling products. there's a huge
difference between pomades, waxes, gels,
hair spray, cream and clay and hey if
you're not sure which products to use
check out my best options in the video
description. another tip I almost feel
like I don't have to really say it
because common sense but improve your
clothing styles. sometimes the clothes do
make the man especially when it comes to
first impressions. so a good tip is to
avoid clothes there are too tight or too
big. if you're not sure what to use again
check out the video description. be
friendly, kind and positive because one
of the most robust findings in
psychology is the halo effect and what
is the halo effect? well it is basically
a bias where you unconsciously take one
aspect of somebody as a proxy for their
overall character. in other words you
basically make an assumption of their
whole personality based on only one
aspect. now it's interesting that
research studies shown that people who
are more kind and positive and friendly
are rated as being more attractive than
other people.
be yourself in all situations
why? well basically let me explain it
this way: being an original is worth more
than a copy. if you get what I mean.
you can always improve on yourself but
never try to be someone that you're not
because you're never meant to be someone
else. you're supposed to be the only you
in this world.
all right the bonus tip: this is probably
the most important tip that a lot of
people out there forget especially in
the world that we live in today. what is
it? it is that beauty is not just about
having a pretty face, it's about having a
pretty mind, a pretty heart and a pretty
soul and remember having a kind and soft
heart in a cruel world is not a weakness
it's courage. all right if you liked the
video give it a thumbs up subscribe and
click the notification bell so you won't
miss any of the next videos that's it
guys Cheers